my mom was in the scream a lot I said
you need to scream a lot like Jojo you
need to keep your volume up like her she
is exposing you right now
Oh Northwest is a Shady Lady the
six-year-old totally through her mom Kim
Kardashian under the bus on Sundays
keeping up for the Kardashians
which gave us a behind the scenes look
at how North filmed her YouTube collab
with Jojo see wha that is how you do it
now when the video dropped in March it
looked like Jojo was babysitting North
for the day but turns out Kim was there
the whole time
keeping an eye on the shoot and playing
cheerleader for North
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
at first Kim said she was nervous to let
North do something so public because it
felt like work to Kim but then she saw
Jo Jo's emerge closet hi babe
so I am in Georgia see was murder and
while North is upstairs look at chief
country this is her dog Miss Piggy sushi
it's a diary she has hair brushes nail
sets keep your look this is the craziest
merch thing okay they're coming I got it
yeah North could be making the family a
lot of money Kim just listen to your mom
I think you just can't take it so
seriously I don't think Kylie ever
really looked at her job as work when
she was that young and I just kept
shocking her money away every time she
did something and one day she said she
wanted to start a lipcott business and
she I said you've got to use all your
own money if you believe in this that
this is yours to build yeah so I think
you can create some boundaries and let
her have fun and now kylie is a
billionaire with a B let that sink in
all right stick with ET as we keep an
eye on all of North's business ventures
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]